the second trailer for x-men dark
Phoenix has finally been released and
whilst it will probably be the final
film for the franchise I'm still quite
excited for it if you've been paying
close attention to the film then you'll
be aware of the various rumors about
reshoots and the fact that the movie has
been pushed back several times
however this trailer confirms that the
film is indeed coming out on the 7th of
June and it gives us a final look at the
movie after its numerous changes
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down everything that you need to know
about the trailer as well as what the
movie could have in store for us there
will be some potential spoilers here so
if you don't want to know anything then
I highly suggest that you turn off now
but with that out the way I'm definition
and welcome to the channel where I
explain it so you don't have to okay so
the first big thing to take from this
trailer is that the movie is indeed
following a similar origin story to the
first Dark Phoenix film x-men and The
Last Stand Professor X is well aware of
genes intense psychic abilities and he's
had to put numerous mental barriers in
place to stop the Phoenix from going out
however this suppression has instead led
to a lot of anger
I think this film's gonna follow Gene's
journey of self-discovery it's a shame
that the film didn't receive its
original release day as a thing that the
Umbrella Academy has just done this plot
motif incredibly well with the white
violin and the film will draw obvious
parallels with that even though x-men
came first from the trailer we can
indeed confirm that this film is very
heavily focused on Jean Grey in the past
the x-men films tended to be centered
around the entire team but there seems
to be more focused on her journey from
first arriving at the x-mansion all the
way up to the 90s Jean is here to break
up the band and I'm glad that she still
pretty much remains the sole focus as
fittingly this will be the last movie of
the franchise however there are other
elements that make it clear that the
x-men are going off in their own
direction it seems like mystique is now
firmly on the side of the x-men after
she jumped back and forth between the
teams and the private homes it also
appears that magneto is forming Genosha
you know she is a new country built in
Africa specifically for mutants and it's
a safe haven for them so it's clearly
confirming that magneto is building this
from the ground up Jessica Chastain is
the most ambiguous character of the
trailer and there have been many
theories that she is a scroll and that
her appearance would be the thing that
ties the Marvel and x-men universe
together however there are also those
who think that she may be a gender swap
of mr. sinister and this would make
sense as he's one of the big bads of the
series that hasn't appeared yet the
trailer also confirms that we are going
to space fans of the Dark Phoenix saga
we'll know that the original Phoenix is
a celestial being that chose Jean as a
host body and it appears that the group
are going into cellar to tackle this
head-on which ties into the original
comics we also know from the last
trailer that mystique will probably die
in this film and this is confirmed in
this trailer at the start of it Jean is
crying at devastated at what she has
done and the grave shot from this
trailer confirms this it's a bit of a
big spoiler and I don't know why it was
included but this will indeed be
Jennifer Lawrence's last film as we know
in the past she's complained about how
much she hates being in the series
judging by the poster it's clear that
the mutants are split down the middle
with even Jeanne herself being this way
and this is confirmed by the fact she
asks herself in an almost Gollum light
way why did you do that if you've read
Avengers vs. x-men then you'll know that
the Dark Phoenix was seen as a positive
for some mutants what's a negative for
others in that book Phoenix came to the
planet to herald a new resurgence for
the meetin's and whilst I don't think
the Avengers will be making an
appearance it could make for a nice
almost Civil War like face-off between
the two sides though she initially seems
to be against Magneto at some points in
the trailer it's also clear that she's
trying to unite the x-men when she saves
them from the Train at the end overall I
really liked the trailer and I can't
wait to see the movie when it's released
in June so what are your thoughts on the
latest trailer and are you excited for
the film I know a lot of people have
been turned off by the franchise
recently but you know I still enjoy
those older movie
x-men was a franchise that I loved
before the Dark Knight trilogy so
hopefully it comes to a fitting end make
sure you leave your thoughts in the
comments below and if you enjoy this
video then please like it and check out
my breakdown of the post-credits scene
of Captain Marvel which will be linked
after this video this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]